good morning thank you very much to
congresswoman fox or welcoming us were
grateful for the courage that she shows
in reminding us that the Constitution
provides constraints and even more that
those constraints in fact are are
limiting but also liberating my name is
David Bob I serve as director of the LNP
Kirby jr. center for constitutional
studies in citizenship at Hillsdale
College were pleased to welcome you all
to this ongoing monthly lecture program
called first principles on first
writings our mission at the kirby center
is an extension of the educational
mission of Hillsdale College an
institution founded in 1844 the kirby
center was much younger we launched only
last fall our mission is to teach
citizens and included the homeless
citizens our students those it was an
undergraduate institution to teach
scholars as well to work with salesmen
and public servants about the enduring
principles of the Constitution and its
so doing to inspire them to inspire
citizens to act worthy of the blessings
of liberty one of the focal points of
the kirby center is the Washington
Hillsdale internship program a program
that for 35 years has invited hillsdale
college students to Washington DC for a
semester long intensive study abroad
program for when you are on the main
campus of Hillsdale College in South
Central Michigan Washington DC and deed
can seem very much like a study abroad
I'm pleased to welcome six of Hillsdale
students who are here today wrapping up
their semester as the 400 employees of
Hillsdale College on our main campus
have just concluded one of the coldest
most snowy winters on record it's
fitting that we now turn to a discussion
of hot air
in fact today's topic is timely
important and very pressing for it
raises the fundamental question of what
framework our public policy questions
will be decided in will that framework
be one in which the Constitution is the
guide or will some other framework
prevail what in short does the
Constitution how to do with
environmental policy hillsdale college
today is delighted to be able to call
upon steve hayward to address this
question few are more qualified than dr.
Hayward to do so he has extensive
experience in a wide range of public
policy issues co-author of the annual
index of leading environmental
indicators her key word is the producer
and host of a DVD I would commend to all
of you it's titled An Inconvenient Truth
or convenient fiction it's a rebuttal of
Al Gore's documentary he's the author of
many books on environmental topics and
each year he contributes in five pulls
together as I mentioned this leading
environmental indicator index he writes
also for AE is environmental policy
outlook series and in fact in addition
to affiliations with many other think
tanks dr. Hayward is the FK weyerhaeuser
fellow at the American Enterprise
Institute he's written widely on other
topics too I commend those books to you
including one that you'll be able to
find later this summer the second in a
tube on new series on the age of Reagan
he's written on the topic of greatness
today he's going to help us understand
better Kyoto and the Constitution
environmentalism and the administrative
state author Steve neighbor
well thank you David and thank you
Hillsdale I noticed on my way to town
this morning the news that our president
is in France or somehow seems
metaphysically appropriate I can say
about that well a climate change is a
big issue these days I suspected some of
you have heard nothing or two about in
the news but is a confused and
increasingly chaotic scene with many
moving parts some of those parts move
the fresh even this week now I think the
issue is changing in real time right in
front of us but I don't want to get
bogged down too far in the details and
lose sight of the central point of this
Hillsdale series which is to highlight
the constitutional defects of the modern
administrative state so there are four
parts of this issue to consider this
morning and then in question period we
can brought it out of people like about
curiosities about this or that aspect of
the subject the first part is this
climate change is the central obsession
of the environmental left today and its
saw puppets on the left in Congress you
know Churchill was to find a thematic as
someone who can't change their mind and
won't change the subject well the issue
of climate change is hired in a
monomania among the environmental left
both as to the nature of the problem and
the range of possible responses to
climate change of any dimension and for
whatever cause for the climate fanatics
change is always catastrophic always
immediate always caused by humans alone
and can only be addressed by one remedy
of huge and hugely expensive reductions
in fossil fuel use well the election of
barack obama has not brought comfort in
competence to the rents of the climate
campaigners to the contrary there is
right now an obvious sense of panic in
the rhetoric of the climate campaigners
as i call them and this panic arises not
simply for the fact that the global
economic crisis is d railing expensive
climate action plans but it's
also from the deeper problem that the
scientific case for catastrophic global
of normative about global warming is
starting to unravel after two decades of
steadily increasing global temperatures
from the late 1970s to the late 1990s
which on the surface seemed to validate
the basic theory of global warming well
there's been no warming for the last
decade maybe even a slight cooling
depending on how you at which data sent
you look at now this was completely
unexpected and is starting to falsify
the predictions of nearly every computer
climate model now the climate
campaigners are engaged in complicated
contortions to explain away this
inconvenient truth but a few more years
of flat or slightly declining
temperatures and the entire issue might
start determined turbine meanwhile many
of the signs and wonders as i call them
they're deployed scared the public are
in retreat as well the Arctic ice cap
bounced back last year after a record
low level in 2007 and by the way almost
all the recent scientific research
suggests that the climb in the Arctic
ice cap we see in the last 30 years was
caused by shifting wing patterns and
ocean currents rather than greenhouse
gases anyway the decline in Greenland's
ice mass which had observed by some data
sets to have been accelerating early in
this decade has now stopped and reversed
itself according to science magazine
just two weeks ago ocean temperatures
appeared to be cooling which confounds
the Orthodox warming theory or at the
very least suggests that our grass where
the issue is not as complete and
definitive as the climate campaigners
tell us the data show that drought has
not increased in the United States over
the last several decades and tropical
storms have entered a quiet period over
the last few years again contrary to the
rhetoric of Vice President Gore and the
climate campaigners so small wonder then
that a whole round of racial opinion
polls by rasmussen by Gallup from the
Pew Research Center show increasing
public skepticism of global warming and
declining enthusiasm for expensive
greenhouse gas emissions reductions in
fact just two weeks ago in gallup's
annual poll on environmental issues for
the first time in thirty
years a majority of Americans say that
economic growth should take precedence
over environmental protection by margin
at fifty one forty two percent the
previous high watermark ever for people
saying the economy's you take precedence
over the environment was only forty four
percent so despite the evidence
suggesting that global warming gives at
worst and exaggerated or overestimated
problem the climate campaigners persist
in demanding only Steve and expensive
near-term emissions reductions even
though there are other cheaper and more
effective remedies such as geo
engineering in the unlikely case that
catastrophic warming a were to come to
pass some decades from now and this
monomania over admissions cuts is
leading to demands for fresh distortions
in our law or policy and an
international diplomacy and this brings
me to the second main point the fixation
with the Kyoto Protocol or what I call
tomorrow Churchill's phrase about
disarmament in the 30s the prolonged and
sullen farce of the Kyoto process the
original chemical protocol of 1998 is
set to expire in another 23 years and
the global climate campaign is
desperately leaded to the idea of
crafting Kyoto to by the end of this
year in Copenhagen talks at which is why
they expected President Obama attend now
the first Kyoto Protocol 1998 which not
even a president gore would have
implemented had he become president in
two thousand has generated the greatest
mass hypocrisy since the kellogg-briand
pact promised in warfare back in
nineteen twenty eight I have little
doubt that in 10 or 20 years we're going
to look back on the Kyoto process as the
climate policy equivalent of wage and
price controls to fight inflation in the
seventies those of you old enough to
remember that idiotic idea the Kyoto
approach has utterly failed to achieve
its first stage goals and the European
claims that you'll hear sometimes in
addressed to have applied with Kyoto the
pan upon some bookkeeping gimmicks that
would have made Enron blush now there
was never any prospect that the United
States was wanting to agree or implement
a treaty whose emissions reductions
would have assured the acceleration of
the
location of American industry overseas
that's why even the most green and
liberal members of the Senate voted by a
margin of 95 204 the bird Hagel
resolution in 1997 which said the
President Clinton please do not bring us
a treaty that does not include the
emerging nations such as China and India
and Mexico and Brazil and that's exactly
the treaty that L more trot back from
Kyoto as at this moment it appears that
any he 02 will have spiritually the same
defect although we can't expect some
fancy footwork and coke admitting it in
December to try and dress up or disguise
that fact now the basic political and
economic calculations behind bird Hagel
are still in place today despite changes
in the membership in the Senate since
1997 that have moved that body to the
left just this week I know that the
Senate passed a series of resolution
saying we want to have emissions trading
or some climate policies that do not
cost anybody anything I noted that these
passed on April first I leave it to you
to decide whether the Senate in fact has
a sense of humor generally you can
answer that question in negative fairly
reliably there's zero chance that aquila
to treaty can achieve the consent of
two-thirds of the members of the Senate
no just to take one example that ohio's
otherwise very liberal senator sherrod
Brown has expressed his opposition to
emissions trading because of its impact
on Ohio's industry so the climate
campaigners are arguing that President
Obama should assume the group of a
formal treaty and instead pursue series
of international agreements in the form
of executive congressional agreements
similar to fast-track trade promotion
Authority that we used to things like
the NAFTA free trade treaty in the 1990s
what this would do is allow President
Obama to pass by leading international
climate obligations that would piggyback
on Kyoto too but with only a simple
majority vote of both houses of Congress
instead of a two-thirds vote by the
Senate well there's several things to be
said about this idea first and most
obviously it shreds the constitutional
for the advice and consent of the Senate
now the Supreme Court has generally
avoided ruling clearly on the
constitutionality an executive agreement
format that we do some trade promotion
promotion Authority I think the Supreme
Court is likely to avoid the matter has
so far as being a political question to
be worked out between the elective
branches however and that's an important
point however there's a very large
substantive difference between bilateral
trade agreements between the United
States and one or two other countries
that are designed to make both nations
more prosperous and an executive
agreement with potentially a hundred and
eighty other countries that will make us
less prosperous and it would have a
significant economic cost there are
obviously very different animals
substantively now the leading advocate
of the executive agreement approach to
climate policy is a fellow named Nigel
purpose of the Brookings Institution who
wrote not long ago quote well he's
arguing that the treaty clauses of the
Constitution are an impediment to
progress and here's his quote the treaty
process created by the framers of the
Constitution requires an exceptional
degree of national consensus that is no
longer reasonable given the frequency
and importance of international
cooperation today we must not cling to
preconceived notions of how our country
negotiates and reviews international
climate agreements close quote the
pleasure of the translation is if the
Constitution stands in the way of a
climate treaty so much the worse for the
Constitution a similar dynamic is
working itself out on the purely
domestic level which is the third moving
part of the story the prospects for the
passage of an emissions trading
reduction plan in Congress do not look
very good at the moment for reasons I
just mentioned chiefly because too many
Democrats in Heartland states that would
be hit hard by sharply higher energy
costs are hesitating or openly opposing
the idea however President Obama's
budget plan has penciled in more than
six hundred billion dollars in revenue
from an emissions trading bill from the
higher costs we'd all pay on are you two
the bills and for gasoline and other
energy and hence the idea has been
floated on attaching emissions trading
through the budget reconciliation
process thus allow him to be passed by a
simple majority vote as a part of the
general budget and making it immune to a
filibuster in the Senate this is
obviously an attempted to end run the
deliberative process of the legislative
branch an emissions trading bill simply
cannot survive the life of a sustained
an open debate in Congress so try and
attach it and pass it without debate now
the idea of pursuing Kyoto to by means
of an executive agreement or a domestic
emissions trading scheme by means of the
budget budget reconciliation process has
stirred up some resistance among members
of Congress who still take seriously the
separation of powers and the
prerogatives of the legislative branch
this is not a brand new idea by the way
an episode that's mostly forgotten
because it disappeared so quickly back
in 1979 Jimmy Carter floated the idea of
trying to adopt assault to arms control
treaty by means of an executive
agreement as a sentence already vote
instead of a formal treaty because he
knew the salt 2 treaty could never get
two-thirds vote of the Senate his
members of his own party told him where
he could put that idea and he abandoned
it and ultimately abandoned the treaty
of course and so the White House is
backtracking on both ideas but don't
expect them to be entirely abandoned
those are always go to measures you will
each one a little tonight when we didn't
know what it's watching and RAM things
through this brings us to the fourth and
final piece of the story regulating
greenhouse gas emissions through the
existing mechanisms of the Clean Air Act
an approach that promises to fuel an
enormous expansion of environmental
bureaucracy on all levels of government
down to local governments and state
government the Clean Air Act of 1990 was
an update of the original Clean Air Act
of 1970 and it specifically targeted
traditional noxious air pollutants at
Harvey human health like ground-level
ozone carbon monoxide lead sulfur
dioxide and nitrogen oxides however the
Clean Air Act also provided
some latitude for the EPA to regulate
unspecified toxic chemicals that install
amounts contribute to pollution on the
local level or post localized health
risks examples would be benzene or
medical chloroform but the Clean Air Act
was never intended to be a vehicle for
the regulation of greenhouse gases for
the mechanism to fight global warming
and is not as we shall see suited to the
regulation of greenhouse gases which are
of a quite different character from
noxious air pollutants in fact dirty Lee
congressional debate in 1990 it was
deliberately decided not to include a
carbon dioxide among the pollutants the
EPA should regulate and indeed it never
even occurred to the regulation happy
Clinton administration to try apply the
Clean Air Act to this issue what what
happened is a sharp case study in the
elasticity to power and the corruption
of law in the modern administrative
state a few years ago frustrated by the
resistance of the Bush administration to
the agenda of the climate campaign
environmentalists brought a lawsuit as
Massachusetts versus EPA decided about
two years ago today that sought to use
the general language allowing the EPA to
regulate newly discovered toxic
pollutants in Section 302 G for those of
you who like to look these things up
they sought to use that general rent
language to compel the EPA to regulate a
especially carbon dioxide from
automobiles essentially the idea was as
a backdoor way of imposing higher gas
mileage standards on the auto fleet well
two years ago as I just mentioned the
Supreme Court watched the decision on
the case citing with environmentalists
that the EPA could regulate co2 as a
pollutant if it may what is known as an
endangerment finding under the Clean Air
Act terms and the names been finding is
a finding that really house gases pose a
threat to the health or welfare of
Americans that's step one of setting
emotional interactive process now in so
finding the court disregarded its own
precedents and most especially in a case
a few years ago called EPA vs
renown in Williamson this was about
whether the FDA could regulate tobacco
smoke from cigarettes and the court said
no it couldn't and some of its language
in brown and EPA vs Brown & Williamson
suggested that Congress would not
delegate major policy decisions quote
such economic and political magnitude
close quote through administrative
agency in quotes so cryptic a fashion in
epa versus brown & williamson they're
also referring to some very general
language suggesting that the EPA's
authority over anything to make her view
was boundless and the court said no but
they said yes in case of mass vs. EPA
well the EPA and issued the endangerment
finding just a couple of weeks ago even
though and probably run with this even
though the factual claims are all
seemingly weak and so the long process
of developing a regulatory regime under
the Clean Air Act for co2 is now
underway well ever since this litigation
began and even in recent weeks since of
the Obama administration arrived in town
it was generally assumed around
Washington that the threat of regulating
greenhouse gases through the Clean Air
Act was purely a political tactic
designed to bring pressure on Congress
to pass a more comprehensive but more
flexible approach to greenhouse gas
emissions reductions like the emissions
trading everyone's favorite
market-friendly a means of doing this
but with the prospect of emissions
trading fading suddenly it's becoming
more likely that the Obama
administration will use the clean air
act as a fallback position in Congress
may well acquiesce because it will
excuse them of the responsibility for
the high costs and chaos it may generate
the irony here is that in mass vs EPA
the court thought it unlikely that an
endangerment finding would lead to quote
extreme measures by the EPA let us see
about this now the millions who brought
the case reported to be seeking
regulations only their automobiles as I
mentioned but this is a disingenuous
argument once a chemical compound is
determined to be
Luton's under the terms of the Clean Air
Act a series of broad regulatory regimes
or potential sources of co2 going far
beyond automobiles are set in motion and
by the way any environmental group can
compel them to be expanded and enforced
through litigation and this is already
happening even before the endangerment
finding has completed its formal review
and before the EPA has begun a long
rulemaking process that often takes
years and by mental groups are already
going Court are a challenging permits
for the construction of new coal-fired
power plants or the expansion that
existing coal-fired power plants citing
the Supreme Court decision as their
basis now there are two main features of
the Clean Air Act that will come into
play first the Clean Air Act requires
the EPA to determine a national ambient
air quality standard and a take us as
the abbreviation or max is the way it's
pronounced you're supposed to determine
a standard or a level for co2 in the air
that protects the health and welfare of
Americans for ozone for example to take
a conventional gluten the standard is
0.75 parts per million over an eight
hour period and there's love science
that shows that going to gets above that
certain sensitive people who have
impaired lung function so forth fine and
dandy but unlike ozone which is a local
pollution pollutant and an evanescent
blue goes away overnight co2 levels are
determined globally not globally or
within the borders of the United States
and if the climate campaigners believe
that we're already above a quote unquote
safe level it will mean the EPA will
have to set a level where we are now or
lower as a target and even in the United
States even if zero co2 it would have no
difference on the global level of carbon
dioxide meaning that it would not change
the so-called danger to health and
welfare of Americans one little bit well
the second thing is is taken to the
extent of the law of the EPA will be
empowered to regulate virtually every
source of co2 not just cars and trucks
and power plants for example one
important feature the thing in Iraq
I think known as the prevention of
significant deterioration ESDS it's
called in the terms of the train and the
PSD requirement means that any new major
source of pollution or the modification
of an existing source that might
increase emissions of any pollutant must
either adopt very expensive control
technologies or the limit emissions or
just find some way to offset their
pollution elsewhere so what is a major
source of air pollution well cleaner
access it's any source that emits 250
tons per year although in some cases
it's as low as 100 tons a year now
that's a lot for things like carbon
monoxide or ozone precursors like
volatile organic compounds it's hard to
anything for co2 to that thresholds so
low that it would cover most office
buildings of any size a large apartment
building string walls any building in
Washington that uses fossil fuels to
keep cool itself will surely reach that
threshold that means that hundreds of
thousands of buildings and businesses
are potentially exposed to regulation
through the Clean Air Act approach to
greenhouse gases and the PSD permit
process is lengthy and expensive and
remember it also allows third-party
environmental lawyers to intervene
relentlessly at every step of the
process increase in both costs and
delays for look at what the future might
bring just look at my home state of
California which has perfected the art
of regulatory expansion suppose for
example in California you want to build
a small strip mall or shopping center or
office building california regulators
refer to such enterprises as indirect
sources of pollution incorrect because
all the building may not admit in the
ozone are carbon dioxide itself it
attracts car trips city so they heaven
it's a destination for automobiles and
so they're allowed in the permitting
process to build something now to take
into account the indirect pollution that
you are building will be responsible or
because people drive there so they do
they have a formal in direct review
process in California and the estimate
pollution will come from all these new
trips of people come to do business with
you and then they charge you a
mitigation fee it varies from County to
County but it's as much as fifty cents
of square foot in some cases of your new
construction now this is called a
mitigation fitty but it doesn't mitigate
anything it's simply more money to pay
for a larger bureaucracy of the air
districts in California recently you may
have heard california regulators
proposed in the last couple of weeks to
outlaw the sales of black cards in
california on the theory that black cars
absorb more heat from the sun in the
summer and therefore use more gasoline
to run their air conditioners in other
words we have arrived at a place in
which the regulators armed with no
affirmative statute or mandate from
Congress and with a policy framework
designed for a very different kind of
problem finds itself limited only by its
imagination which as you can see is
quite expensive and with no effective
constraints from positive law or the
Constitution and this is merely one
aspect of the modern revolution in
government form of a series of by now
very old errors in our constitutional
construction that have delegated
legislative power to independent
agencies and hero to the separation of
power that was considered a key bulwark
of liberty by men who wrote the
Constitution in 1787 this is a long and
complicated story that defies simple
solutions or easy remedies or the
rehearsal of just a handful of Supreme
Court precedents above all of the root
of the administrative state we see
galloping along at a quicker pace even
before President Obama came into office
if the set of ideas a progressive
government that sees the Constitution's
meaning as unfixed to be determined by
the tides of history which somehow
always seem to be running all in the
direction of increasing government
control over people and enterprise at
some point we need to engage in a
serious in serious thought about
reforming administrative law reforming
regulatory procedure with new limits on
congressional delegation a new
rules on standing for third-party
intervention and generally about the
nature and limits of government power in
a globalized world of advanced
technology I'll close with this and
goodness we have hillsdale college to
help carry on this important work else
who wants to go first time I'll never
must ask the first question I was trying
to plant one that I calculate this
morning yes sir are you planning in
watching the what is the likelihood of
being able to reverse some of these what
is the likelihood of being able to
reverse some of these decisions allowing
departments to just regulate that thin
air to just all of a sudden to side you
know you can't have a black car anymore
yeah some of these decisions that are
ongoing you know the EPA what's the
likelihood of ever getting back into
that well you know I mean I studied
these these matters I'm not a lawyer but
you know I studied Constitutional
History didn't handle these things work
I think it's a mistake and that the
courts are going to fix it with two or
three more good appointments I mean
we're all for that but I think I think
Congress especially Congress needs to
assert itself and the current number so
obviously they like all the stuff but
Congress at some point needs to assert
itself and rewrite some basic regulatory
statutes a few things that nearly
happened in the 1990s one little thing
that was a partial victory was requiring
agencies to use more less cost benefit
analysis so that if you're going to
impose a regulation the benefits should
be higher than the costs otherwise an
environmental level alone if you're
wasting money you're wasting resources
but which probably is not good for the
environment at the end of the day and
it's very hard to get Trimble Orthodox
environmentalist so I think the Congress
needs to reassert itself the executive
branch can also try this look I've
coming out in the summer about rigging
and talks a lot about their initiatives
try and discipline of bureaucracy which
was a big success because they sometimes
they fell victim to and had court
decisions from Congress which was
hostile to some of these reforms and the
media which is always against them so
it's a hard hard problem but adult don't
phone racing these simple idea that we
just get a new case in a new justice on
the court that will fix everything will
help but that's the problem is deeper
and requires I think forward action from
the other branches first house yeah let
me get we overspent what do you think
that the spike that puts global warming
hosing to bed will be is there any one
event or a study that could put the
monster back in its cave no I mean look
at me i didn't use this in my text and
putting my tax but i thought about
putting in there that it's amazing to
see what is I follow public opinion
polls closely it's amazing to see public
resistance rising to all this after
people like album or have spent
literally hundreds of millions of
dollars in public education advertising
campaigns I mean they've got laborious
product sends the Etzel that's what was
the more successful marketing effort and
this has been and so I think you know if
you want to point to some things you
know they thought hurricane katrina was
their bread for a moment and they're
still dining out on that and really
wasn't and the reverse would be if we
have some more really cold winters here
around the world you know I just think
it's going to row bit more and more and
ascend to this what's happening on that
is really fascinating to watch the
so-called mainstream science scientists
been publishing a series of studies in
the last year saying oh you know we
think now maybe global warming's going
to pause for 10 or 20 years this goes
completely against the theory that says
it should be burrito what's happening
right now all models take all the sweets
models that run the same temperature
should be doing this and you've been
going like this and so now we're waiting
below the lowest ballad of all the main
models that continues to go on and
pretty soon you can't keep this up so I
don't think I don't think it would ever
be a decisive moment you say it's over
you may on the policy front see a few
nations abandon the they're crazy
commitments some of the Europeans are
close to that actually but i think the
trajectory of this issue is going to
follow the trajectory of the population
control movement of the middle part of
the 20th century which is still around
but nobody pays that much attention to
it and even the UN 15 years ago said
population is now a less important issue
than we once thought it was and there's
a great book on this out last year
called the fable misconception by
liberal historic actually columbia
university published by harvard
university press and if you read this
it's a this guy bunch of all files of
the population controllable
organizations international planned
parenthood and we should was the you
know the self-dealing and political
corruption of these groups total
disregard of the facts and as you read
this if you just swap out climate change
for population it reads like a perfect
description of the whole climate change
game going on with the UN's IPCC today
so I'd be I think something grind along
for a long time but I think it's you
know or the other marker right I think
about is you know my magazine whenever
it's stuck what's climate change on its
cover they've got more global warming
covers in the other magazine well the
end of last year the magazine trade
publishing people whoever they are
little survey discovered the green
issues that everybody puts out in April
were the worst selling newsstand issues
for everybody then in fair time
everybody else one of these days the
editors are going to get their meeting a
Time magazine if there still is a Time
magazine the prints on paper and
someone's gonna say we're stuck for
cover some will say let's do a little
warming again one day we'll be ready to
say you know that's not you know because
we don't do it we don't you covers on
population bond anymore which you
remember back in the late 60s it was
huge right and so I think it's going to
slowly fade away it will never go away
but it was slowly fade away and you know
all these climate groups are going to
take on the character of the world
Esperanto Association I find my
let's be hard yeah so there were the
full-page ad in honey was the post this
week on monday k go ad with all these
scientists because I is questioning
essentially that whether or not the
claim is actually changing I'm wearing
which I thought significant but I
looking at your thoughts on it and then
the second question is so do you think a
climate cap-and-trade bill will actually
pass the Congress and get signed by the
president um you know I mean the
establishment on this is so as I said my
Marcus is so called the mom mania that
no amount of Freeman Dyson was on the
cover of the new york times magazine
last week and he's a famous lefty you
couldn't get any better crime
credentials than him and you know he's a
skeptic all this quite open licenses all
nonsense and you know we agreed what
goes on the blogosphere is like first of
all there's true two actions this is you
know what's wrong with dice and labeled
man so it's obviously senile the other
one is lack of the New York Times do
that to us you know that was a monopoly
on this so I've been good for KO for
doing that I don't think that has much
effect unfortunately I don't think an
emissions trading labels going to pass
unless it's completely falling and does
nothing in other words said I'm actually
going to spend I'm going to ruin most
the rest of my day reading through the
waxman-markey bill that came out earlier
in the week there's two things notable
about it one is it's called a discussion
daft you always know when something's
call discussion for app I don't think
it's going to get through anything
resembling that form and second it
leaves completely bang all the big
questions as to how many emissions
allowances are you going to sell or give
away and and that's what the whole game
is really and how are you going to try
and keep people from noticing or
painting higher energy costs and no one
can figure that problem out because it
can't be figured out um so I you know I
think you're going to say we will need
to put this off till next year don't be
that you know I want to direct that
document what's that you aren't you you
yeah no one no legislature will before
they vote it at least it smells nice
at least it's in big prints so but
that's why this whole business the whole
EPA oh there's one sentence in the
maximum marquee bill that would remove
from the EPA the authority to regulate
greenhouse gas emissions under the Clean
Air Act well this is interesting
Congress should all along and so that
that's a sort of odd little things
floating out there i'm not quite sure
who that's trying to bait they might
think there must be a handful of
Republicans who will fall for that trick
but that's why now this idea that we'd
regulate the Clean Air Act which you
notice as I try to describe in a couple
ways it's completely inappropriate to
this problem setting aside major
problems so forth that's looking at more
likely and then that will allow
President Obama to show up in Copenhagen
sand we are going to do something about
it we're going to use our you know we're
going to use a bill that was first
passed my law passed by President Nixon
long bipartisan support has been
effective for everything else will say
things like that and you know the
European black by that but of course you
know it can take ten years for a major
rule regime to get through all the
procedural hurdles you have to go
through the clean air act so if I'm
environmentalists who seriously thinks
this is a problem this really isn't a
very good answer because in the mean
years and years of delay and lots of
contentiousness and so this is a really
no huge mess the thing you had granted
up I think that you were what if you did
okay thank you some people have said
that journalism died in the two thousand
eight election and most people think
there's media bias engineering here some
people have said that that the
journalism has died that it's dead in
two thousand eight election as people in
this room probably think there's media
bias how do you grade right now the
media the journalists and over the next
10 years or anything what look ready
would you give them
your protection well I mean media
coverage and environmental issues
generally gets an ass that's a
gentleman's F I mean it's so bad it's
the worst of anything and oh I'm not
going a long time about that will it get
any better I don't know it's not a thing
the problem of environmental journalism
is you have the true believers are going
to it because they want to save the
world they're going to be Woodward and
Bernstein for the environment so giddy
logically ill-disposed to you need fair
reporting then you have other people who
end up in the beat because no one else
at the paper wants to cover it and they
actually literally draw straws and who s
the short straw has to cover the
environment this actually washington
post their reporters usually a political
reporter who has to do environment for a
while they're not good at it the new
york times at least has reporters with
serious credentials humanity brecon
italy knows a lot about science and
they've got a few PhD ppl phd's and
sciences on their pages doing reporting
and so they're reporting in the ordinary
sense is better than most serious and a
somewhat more depth to it even though
Revkin is totally in the bag alarmist
you at least can have a sensible
conversation with it or sometimes
talking to I don't mention the names of
the post blundell a use been covered
environment it's like talking to a child
I mean just impossible and the party
comes out and completely distorted abaya
stand so i don't know that will change
or not because especially with a media
organization shrinking and the fact that
you know beyond the small number of
people who are fanatics about the
subject most people don't find a subject
very interesting I have you know reader
surveys and all the polls or the pupil
and January's you know gay people Tony
issues the global warming was mentioned
as an issue for importance it came out
20th well this is not lost on editors
and so I know if lover get any better
you know now that you might find a
contrary reporter who decides to that
there's an opportunity to go the other
way New York Times had a guy in 1992
Nikki Schneider here and they did a
four-part front page feature series
about you know unorthodox views of the
environment it's quite a good series
from my point of view and
he got drummed out of the times pretty
fast I mean it was politically
environmentally incorrect like oh
there's political correctness of iron
malpractice and it still got a real
spammable over the covered you this so
you know you have to be almost
bulletproof like John Stossel to be able
to report the contrary fashion and
survive very long in newsroom so I know
he hasn't received any awards recently
nobody gets big contracts coming this
bra as he gets ratings and that you know
that still speaks a lot for in the media
world PDA what's expected to go to
another network at the network you know
ABC jerking around and under them
wrapping a second yeah in the bottle of
that it's going to wind up finally
punching through the media to win the
battle I mean just is with the dan
Rather George Bush assassination in the
election season that they had they can
only get so far out on this limb until
it's either going rotten break home or
somebody's going to come in behind a
month the bloggers did and saw the limb
off yeah and penetrate that thing and I
can't recall the name of the guy for
usually but he was up here in a briefing
on with him on the Senate side and he
said you know the only climate denier
that we're going to talk to as a senator
inhofe the rest of them forget them so
dr. Wilson who at MIT is awful as they
were doing the same thing the IPCC did
except accurately reporting on the full
scope of literature pure off the list
but at some point something's gotta
penetrate this it'll knock it down so
though you're strong ahead and tell us
yeah the time he gets through well if
you know any type of the population
peril or your parallel again and
actually think this was the turning
point in this country it was about
nineteen 70 or 71 your president nixon
appointed a commission to investigate
population problems to the US of a
population policy and you know this is
the cover stories of Rockefeller
Foundation
pushing us behind scenes and you have to
hold the UN population people were at
high pitch in the early 70s this is the
politics book at the 30 million copies
s7 45 languages or something so we know
their start staying going yeah maybe we
need to have you know some kind of
fertility policy of America and all more
than two children per family and some
date the meeting raise their hand and
said hmm have you noticed who that's
really going to affect the worst well
minorities that Commission was never
heard from again went away at Babel did
they make that thing go away so fast as
it was politically incorrect right well
I think the similar dynamic is playing
out now I mean my observation when I
testified a marquee committee a few
weeks ago as the Republican witness and
what was amusing beyond this works you
have three and the geordie witnesses in
one or maybe two public witnesses and
what inserted about this was two things
one is it really was the stair in the
pit of despair for a lot of the
Democrats but even know about the
subject but the world's coming them in
tomorrow and if we don't do something
really big right now you know what I'll
do it that's the characterization with
it most people send their opening
statements that go on forever right the
second thing was they were terrified of
voting for a bill that's going to cost
anybody anything and I thing was is that
the details of this but the the
Democratic witnesses we're actually
going to helpful other case because
they're saying well we need to have
rebates to people utility company are
saying give us the rebate and we'll pass
them along to customers lana wa I'll
sure you will you trust you on that one
had work that way in Europe yet Fred
Greenstein the Center for budget
priorities say let's just give you know
liebigs directly to consumers and that's
where I said how you going to do that
your consumers Washington State those
low carbon energy will make out like
bandits because everybody's won't look
at all the lowest rates in the country
from all hydropower and they talked up
at all and so they get a windfall
whereas people in Indiana Ohio Kentucky
who have coal-fired electricity their
rates a lot and you won't
them whole and you can see the wheels
turning how is that going to play in a
congressional district in the Midwest
that congressman acts voted to give
money those people sipping coffee and
listening to grunge Ryan Seattle at the
end of the hearing it was quite clear
that there's so there's I think that's
where the issue terms are mountain
policy political terms the sign is a
good take forever to slowly as i say a
real good way I think but now into the
game is are you really going to cast the
vote and even watch the Obama people
that are other backtracking so fast out
of Europeans we're not sure we can match
those targets yeah the Obama people are
saying kind of things that whenever the
bush people said they were called every
bad name in the book write and
understand the same thing because
they're steering some reality of the
things so that's where I think it starts
to marry someone else let's see can we
get over here and Indian what's going to
happen to all the trash to the budget
that they're how to put on today oh I
have no idea i mean as you know we'll
let get cleaned up as the sum of those
puffs take it out of it as it
implemented here i have no idea i'm not
a budget expert it just seems difficult
to me I mean I have talked a couple
people in the agency career people I
know who say they're doubling our budget
one years we have no idea how we can
spend that kind of money let alone spend
it sensibly I mean I so they're going to
be some scandals out of all this so you
don't actually due to the time spent at
all gentlemen bag had a question and
then we'll ran for the time being too
optimistic
sir the global population effort didn't
have the same kind of extensive
regulatory and legal structure that
environment illusion is so when the
environmental movement hopefully does if
you pushed off the stage how do you sort
of undo all of this infrastructure that
sort of cemented in that yeah that's
going to be very hard it's going to take
well let me just step back and say that
tub you know right now especially when
conservatives the urgent topic is you
know how do we publish this enormous
explosion government see right in front
of us there are a few but sitting around
saying yes that needs to be done but we
also need to think about how do you
govern next time you have the
opportunity to govern and you don't
squander your opportunities as I argue
the bush administration did last lot of
the last eight years that's why I have
some interested in the Reagan experience
because they understood the problems and
you know tried some solutions and made
some progress and some and not others
and so if there's ever better chance of
that so the point is the answer that
question is wrapped up in some larger
questions of reform that goes across the
board and I say those are hard I
mentioned just to the previous outline
you know we need to rethink the question
of delegation of essentially lawmaking
Authority to independent agencies all
kinds of things I mean I know there's
this train wreck to anyone right now
with the Consumer Product Safety
Commission it's implementing a statute
that Congress passed but was so badly
fought through that you know you can't
entirely blame me it's like the IRS the
IRS says we're just implementing the tax
code Congress hands us which is right so
I know those problems are you know big
big problems that require a lot of
serious thought and a lot of blueprints
before you actually get another
Conservative administration seems to me
because by then is if you were if you're
six months and still appointing people
is too late some census the reigning
people at least came into office with a
plan I say so much work some that didn't
and that experience needs to be fobbed
out an emulated and improved upon so
that's pretty general not good enough
but that's the way we ought to be
thinking
about this long term when you take the
long people of some of these things
Brandi you have a question let me give
you a microphone they won't hear you
we're still building I'm still paying
for the alcohol hey mr. Obama says a lot
about transparency kind of an all show
where they'll go position but how do
they use transparency given your
thoughts on we need more exposure what's
going on out there how would you use
transparency to really open this debate
up either on Capitol Hill or the media
in our of the public your balls yeah
well I mean I suppose there's the data
quality act which I'm not really an
expert about but you know some of these
I mean I don't know I hate hate I'll
give you an example of you know the
endangerment finding EP is just done on
this thing carbon dioxide is a danger to
public health even on the alarms own
terms if you accept the Orthodox theory
your decades away from any of those
harms those problems don't exist right
now which is unlike traditional air
pollutants we're all sort of it does
harm you right now and and so Pat miles
and caicos magnificent taken out of all
the claims that they're saying that
harms right now and it diseases and I'm
happy his filing the EPA was 300 pages
long I think you can get it off k to the
website and recommend go to work Hollis
Wow and you know it's what's the old
mark 20 liner or whoever it was I got my
mind and don't confuse me the facts I
got my mind made up regular I think it
was you know we've had to be like you
know angle biting mosquitoes or
something constantly prodding the
National Academy of Sciences of the
climate change science project and all
these folks to poke holes in their data
the media does not pay attention to that
is not interested in it and I think most
people in public don't really have the
the interest in following that closely
for actually very sensible reasons why
do I want you know how men ordinary
citizen out and kind of beside why do I
want to spend a lot of time on the
internet reading up on this life and be
watching something fun a TV you're
playing with my kids you know there's
some sense to all that how I think that
much better approach is the political
one of I think we need to piggyback
these tipet tea party people and we want
to go to meetings of your member of
Congress and just simply ask the
question why do you want to raise my
energy prices just do that and you know
eventually did you know though I'm
student Rome juices on the other parts
that I didn't have some confidence in
science I mean it's badly politicized
but it is an iterative process you do
see you know I followed I try to follow
as much of the peer-reviewed literature
as I can and you see every week
heterodox or contrary findings being
published at some point that's going to
tell i think i will tell you one other
story i dunno hey this was off the
record so i shouldn't say his name but
even leading climate scientists had one
of the major institutions whose a
moderate I mean he thinks this might be
a very serious problem but he's honest
enough to say i don't really know
there's so much we don't know that we
should be going off alka he doesn't like
or even gorgeous cited him and it's a
little leading universities he says my
single biggest problem right now is
getting graduate students and physics
the top ones to go into climate science
how's it standard to hear that all the
money sloshing around this is why not
just because they all think it's a dead
end subject they don't like how
politicized it is they think it's a
lousy career path and he says so if you
look closely a lot of people who publish
in this field are not really physicists
or wants to go find a scientist their
biologists ecologists people change from
the softer disciplines and your that i
think is going to catch up to it at some
point I thought that was really fast as
the guys been doing climate science for
30 years it is a long time and I just
thought that I've never heard this
before I thought that was an astounding
thing for what the top guys there's a
straight shooter and you weren't very
sensitive subject to say but that's
where it is so I think I think
publicsex the question yeah it seems to
be based on what you were saying and
based on my observations here that one
of the best things that could be done
would be somebody like AEI or Cato to do
an evaluation of many of these
regulations and put a dollar figure to
them here I heard for years that
regulations have driven out the cost of
a home thirty percent unnecessary
regulations I think if we could have
somebody to a serious study of the cost
and present those and get them out it
would be one of the most important
things that could be done because the
American people really do pay attention
when you show them how much something
costs and I think being able to take
this term cap and trade and call it cap
and tax has been a very very useful
thing to have been able to admit to do
in terms of getting people's attention
so if you all could come up with a way
to do that and say this is how much the
EPA Clean Air Act is costing you as an
individual it would be very helpful yeah
the where networks on this game by the
way I mean them something I learned
actually for one of your new colleagues
Tom McClintock I've known for years in
California yeah well you know his hits
us a simple gimmick that sounds majority
is not you know he keep makes the point
in especially these days of
trillion-dollar deficits in eight
hundred billion dollar bailout you say
that something costs country two hundred
billion dollars sort of an abstraction
what's that you know he always
translated the costs per household this
regulation will cause each family in
California eight hundred dollars now you
know when the Clean Air Act costs people
that amount but it's embedded in all the
costs they don't see but people do see
their utility bills and they see the
price on the gas pump every week that's
why this issue works for us better than
some of these others so that's why I
always say is don't use those my eyes
glaze over
that we all use on Capitol Hill use the
per capita perhaps whole number and
that's why it happened others have been
doing some work on how much is going to
raise your utility bill depending on how
the scheming use I think that's what's
frightening so many of the Democrats is
that realize you can't hide those costs
you can't say the estimates wrong
because you will actually see it on your
bill so yeah more power to you know
where we're going to do a movie nut
butters going to be the promise with
waxman-markey when they don't specify
how many of these things are going to be
auctioned or given away and what the
backfill mechanism might be it's very
hard to reliably estimate so you gotta
get ranges anything else doctor Thank
You Jenny thank you all presentation of
a lot of information very complex and
difficult to follow very simplified
thank you and we're really glad it's
going to be eventually available on our
podcast that we're getting better and
better be patient with us as we get a
website up and give these things more
air and more people will be able to view
your talk thank you Steve and Thank You
Virginia Foxx for hosting us today we
really appreciate your presence and your
leadership especially on the Rules
Committee where you continue to ask very
tough questions and show amazing
principled leadership very creative
leadership and we really appreciate what
you're doing in Congress for all of us
whether we're from North Carolina or not
let me just mention as we depart today
that we have to future events on the
fifteenth of April at eleven o'clock at
the hotel Phoenix which is steps away
from the union station metro will have a
book amount which Mark Levin it's going
to be limited space so it's feeling
quick
if you're interested in coming please
make sure your RSVP'd with our office
because it is filling up fast and he's
got a very hot book liberty and tyranny
right now our next event for the first
principles on First Fridays will be with
RJ post read oh and it's down going to
be compliments of Grover Norquist at the
Americans for Tax Reform and so again
right off the metro this time so we
appreciate everybody going on the
scavenger hunt with us month by month
around the city in the area of finding
good speakers and good company and we
encourage you to do that take a look at
the Krauthammer article op-ed today it
casts the Constitution as the one that's
being forgotten in the midst of the
agenda in town so it's very clear very
good very appropriate for this group Len
would be available for work Marse books
will be available for purchase you won't
have time to individually sign them that
he's going to give us some bookplates to
use that day thanks for asking have a
great weekend and thanks for joining us
so early
you